yo so scottie pippen has just been
wiling in the media last week he went to
kevin durant he said the reason they
lost they didn't play team ball
kevin durant bodied him and was like
isn't this the same guy that wouldn't go
in
when phil jackson drew up the play for a
teammate for the better shooter yeah for
the better shooter yes
uh then this this guy never never had a
jump shot in his life i don't know why
the [ __ ] he want to take that shot
i've never seen skye pippen hit jump
shot even when he was playing i would
see him take jump shots
for when he was playing for the rockets
i was like why is this guy shooting the
ball i've never seen you make jump shots
you defend [ __ ] and you lay it
in that's it
and you pass and you pass it was a great
it was that point
ben simmons back when shooting wasn't as
important there you go
they got carried by michael jeffrey
jordan you had a great sneaker scottie
pippen so i think you got a little bit
elevated in the way that you were
remembered but the reality is is the
game was not complete yeah
that's true great defender could get to
the cup
but could not shoot the ball so the play
should have been called up for tony
coach and he hit the [ __ ] shot how
you still bitter about winning the game
get the kid's a shot with you on the
bench
it's pouting that's what he's
complaining about racism from
so he said phil jackson was racist and
that's why he drew up the play for tony
kulgus because he's a racist and he also
said that michael jordan passed the ball
to uh steve kerr
was for the cameras it was for the
cameras because in the finals it was
game one of the finals against the jazz
one of the years
they have jordan on the bench saying to
steve kerr if they double me i'm coming
to you be ready to take the shot
there's a game-winning shot and steve
kerr's like i'm ready i'll be ready and
then that's exactly what happens they
double jordan kicks out to curry nails
the three they win the game but jordan
said that to him like that's not why he
was brought to the team
like steve kerr wasn't hey you we'd like
you to dominate the ball
and uh yeah yeah you're the big man
defender and maybe going to post a
little bit no you were there for when
the black guys get double
yeah you're wide open around that arc
that's real far away from the rim we
need a white angel yeah there you go
we need guys i got a basketball player
to score a hoop all right come on
it's like michael jordan described his
job description you know yeah you're
right no you're right you think steve
carr was like they're not going to
inbound it to me
what's going on here i thought i'm
talking about dribble out the clock and
then i'd cross over
yeah i make magic happen that's a good
point
that's a good point but here's what i
realize scotty pippen is doing he's got
a memoir coming out
oh now all of a sudden it makes sense
there you go now he's just trying to
grab that i i looked yeah i kept reading
and then it says he has some memoir
coming out and this is what a [ __ ]
loser scottie pippen is is why don't you
just do a memoir about how your
wife is getting railed out by the entire
nba yeah
who's not racist is larsa pippen
larson pippen is an open-minded ass
woman you know because she's been
getting cracked open
and cleaned out by the whole league and
she has been going down
in skill level like scotty is a top 50
player of all time probably yeah right
and she's [ __ ] like not even the best
player with that name
right like who malik beasley right yeah
he's not even the best beasley
was it better beasley that left-handed
beasley who's a little crazy tomorrow oh
no no no no he was the number two pick
overall wasn't michael beasley michael b
michael beasley way better beasley yeah
he's like big delante yeah
he's a little kooky you know i won't
call him crazy no more because the
britney combo will be a little bit kooky
got the tattoos and [ __ ] didn't smash
lebron's mom you think lebron made
delante crazy after smashing his mom
i would like [ __ ] with his meds and
[ __ ] like that wait what happened yes
oh yeah delante west was [ __ ] down
lebron's mom during the playoffs
yeah allegedly this is all a legend yeah
you know thank you very much
you never heard this story oh this is
great and then he literally went crazy
and he was on the side of the highway
like begging for cash
yeah yeah yeah for years yeah anyway it
was like homeless i mean it was bad
bad situation he needed a
conservatorship he needed smoking at his
conservatory
yes yeah man a little crazy a little
crazy
but back to the scottie pippen [ __ ] it's
just so weird man it's just
it's just pathetic yo top 50 player of
all time you're rich just [ __ ] chill
just relax and his team ball comment
about kevin durant
uh he also i don't want to pull up the
exact quote but something he said
something to the effect of
michael jordan and i were really great
on the court off the court we
weren't really good friends and i didn't
like how i was depicted in
in the media where he got all the credit
one player got all the credit and
basketball is a team sport
the credits should go to the team which
is [ __ ] ridiculous right but also
that's why
oh kevin durant didn't win because he
didn't play team ball never mind the
fact that he was one tow away from
hitting the greatest game winner maybe
we've ever seen
right to win a whole [ __ ] series but
he's like oh he didn't play team ball
that's why he lost he just wants to get
his own credit
yeah basketball is not an individual
sport it's a team sport nah it's an
individual sport
that's why you individually have zero
rings
but so does jordan that's true i mean we
can't deny the effect that scotty had on
on i mean he's literally one of the 50
best players of all time
yeah he can't shoot the ball but an
unbelievable force out there yes and to
have a guy that size who can handle the
ball
and defend and pass like it was very
impressive yeah what he did he changed
the position
yeah but jordan got rings without
scottie pardon jordan got rings without
scottie no no never without scotty now
he's on the pony without tommy oh yeah
she did it but he was there for all
steps yeah and uh and there was drama
yeah but but he was there and i think
jordan said look that's my best teammate
ever and
he's very clear about the effect that
scotty had on the team so you can't take
that away from him but
it just does suck that like he's got a
resort
to that in order to sell ranks because
if phil was racist
why don't you say something when he was
the coach of the lakers like why don't
you stop racism why don't you stop the
promotion razor why don't you say
something when he was on a knicks
like if phil is this great racist that
all of a sudden all these black
people exalt these these these black
figures
exalt as one of the greatest mentors of
all time yeah
not just coaches but like the way that
kobe speaks about phil
the way that nj speaks about phil shark
even jack loves phil you know
so it's like it's kind of weird like you
were the only person that he's racist to
because
you can't shoot yeah do you think he
ever had a game winner where kobe or
michael wasn't taking the shot yeah
he was like hey sasha vuchvitch or
whatever the [ __ ] this game one is for
you
never bro that's [ __ ] arrogant he's
racist because he didn't think you could
shoot better than the white guy from
europe
like you always pass it to the white guy
from europe
i get annoyed when i watch in the league
and i see white guys hit shots
from three point because i'm like that's
why they're there
like you can play up on them because
they're not blowing by you
and going to the cup he's getting their
face you know what they're gonna do
close out yeah every time you close out
yeah especially if they're
foreign if they have an accident if
they're going past bus if you can hear
an accident
when they're calling for the rock you
jump
you know they're shooting right it's
unbelievable right right
so the fact that it's racist that he
didn't ask you to miss the last
shot when you knew you [ __ ] would in
a regular season game
low-ass stakes yeah who's the [ __ ] dog
grow up bruh
nah that's whack i'm gonna probably
trust kobe shaq
and michael when it comes to racism over
scotty yeah but it would be funny if if
if phil was the one that told michael
like look republicans bought sneakers
like all of a sudden like all the things
that like fit like phil is the one that
made shaq become a sheriff
you should really get into policing blue
lives matter man blue lives matter
you know that's yeah phil's like i think
you should date a mexican
i think that there and you can be
culturally way more aligned with your
values
like what if it turns out feels really a
racist and he instills sneakily all
these racist values